觉得你存在他的生命里的话，
你一直在给他拖后腿，
你没有给他带来任何的有价值的东西，
所以他瞧不起你，
你现在还没有说一分钱不挣呢，
你现在还挣着钱呢，
他都会觉得你是花了他的钱，
等到你怀孕生孩子的时候，
你分不挣你真的花他的钱的时候，
那个时候我跟你说，
在他眼里的话，
看你怎么看都不顺眼。
我跟我老公是二二年认识的嘛，
当认识的时候他是工作不稳定，
第一年跳槽跳四次的那种，
因为当时其实我已经29岁了，
是年龄焦虑嘛，
家里人给的压力也挺大的，
然后我就选择了一个人结婚，
结婚这两年多，
就是他还是得一年就算跳两三个三四个公司，
这样子就很不稳定，
所以我就一直没敢要小孩，
他一直又要小孩嘛，
我们这个问题就产生分歧了，
7月份的时候就结这个事情，
就是我们已经闹到要到那个某局去了，
然后都登记了，
工婆又很强，
是控制欲很强的那种，
大工司也很强势嘛，
我老公就有一点妈吧，
综合他本身工作这个原因，
还就是说国家的那种环境这两个原因，
我没敢要小孩，
这两年我现在就是有点想撤的那种，
如果说他三番五次的换工作，
你有没有总结一下他换工作的原因是什么，
他就是不会让自己受委屈的那种，
就是领导说就如是他工作做的不对，
他就不愿意听，
他自己就要掉头就走，
就辞职不干，
从来。
都意识不到自己身上的问题，
出现任何事儿都是别人的问题，
可以这么描述他吗？
对，
他平时跟你生活的时候，
也是什么事儿都是怪你头上吗？
对，
就是很多事情都是这样子，
我也引导过他很多次，
我说你在一个公司上班，
他说你做几年，
你至少一个公司做满一年再跳，
这样子也稳定一点，
就是我一直跟他讲，
我说我们定一点，
但是他听不进去，
我现在的情况就是他每次跳槽他都不跟我讲，
他就悄悄的跳槽的那种，
那他自己原生家庭是个什么情况，
他爸妈是干啥的呀？
懂你妈那种，
就是在外地，
就是打工上工地那种，
因为他也是没有管教的，
那你们现在经济上是个啥情况呢？
有什么财产呢？
他频繁跳的，
但是他每个月工资还是给到我这里的，
存一块10个W，
其实这10个W都是他的工资我存下来的，
然后我自己的工资这块我就用于生活开支了，
那总共是换了多少工作了，
从我二二年认识他可能有十五六个了，
到今天为止，
我感觉他是不是靠换工作挣钱呀，
就说老板要开他还得给他赔偿，
他是不靠这个挣钱呀，
不是，
不是他们那种，
就是小企业开除是没有赔偿的，
换那么多工作这事儿确实是个大问题，
因为我考虑的就是他对自己的职业上来都如此任意妄为，
我想如果以后有小孩，
他对家庭对小孩又会多有责任心的，
你这么。
想是有一定道理的啊，
那你现在想要问我的问题是啥呀？
我们就是吵架的这个情因说聊了一遍，
然后他现在意思也就是说，
因为我们结婚两奶多，
我没跟他生小孩儿，
他说那随便你，
你愿意过就过，
就不愿意这里，
但你愿意离婚我就配合你，
你爸妈是干啥的呀？
我们家做了一个脚本买卖的那种，
那你自己大概一个月挣多少钱呀？
我可能就5000块钱，
他那头换工作，
他一个月能挣1万块钱是吗？
差不多有的时候八九千，
有的时候以外，
这样除了他换工作之外，
他生活上到底是什么样啊？
家务做吗？
对你有关心吗？
他不会关心人的，
那我举个例子啊，
就是去年，
就是我在健身房手都骨折的那天，
我让他来接我，
后面就是肿起来了，
我去药店，
然后那个医生就说你最要去拍一下片，
他就不太想带我去，
因为他觉得就是说我的钱都花了，
好像要花他的钱不检查费一样，
他好像就不乐意的那种，
那如果是这样的话，
咱就早点止损吧哈，
家里的父母反正他不支持我离婚，
我今年32岁嘛，
你你32岁你离了你咋办？
就是我也挺焦虑的那种，
对，
我现在也不敢跟我爸妈讲，
因为我一讲他们就说你不要离婚，
所以这一次我想的是如果离婚我就先离，
我离了婚两个月我再跟父母讲，
是这样啊，
姑娘你看啊，
你现在找的这个人，
第一他不关心你是吧，
你生病了他都不舍得花钱去送你去医院。
那你想象一下，
将来你怀孕生孩子这个过程当中呢，
如果面对一个不关心你的人在你的身边的话，
你是什么样的境遇呢？
对，
这也是我这两年没要小孩考量的一个原因嘛，
你应该庆幸现在还没有小孩儿，
你还可以重新选择，
因为我存了10个W，
我可以把这笔存款都给他，
在我们结婚的时候，
有10个W那个彩礼，
然后有3个W拿到三金，
然后他的意思就是说当我另外再给他拿3万，
我说那也行也行啊，
别让人经济上吃亏啊什么的，
和平以后我觉得就说出点钱，
我觉得这个能接受解忧善缘吗？
好聚好散哦，
就是我去年骨折了一次，
那天晚上，
哎呀，
我看出他其实不特了意带我去，
但是后面呢，
他又骂骂咧咧开车带我去了，
就是他要做一件事情，
他做，
但是他嘴上又抱怨的不行，
那你愿意以后你怀孕生孩子的时候是这样一种状态吗？
比如说骂骂咧咧的给你去交手术费，
骂骂咧咧的给你打一个无痛，
骂骂咧咧的给你是吧，
买点什么东西你愿不愿意，
我不愿意，
我不想活在那种状态下，
就是他特别抠，
还是那句话，
姑娘啊，
杀伐决断的女人才有好日子过啊，
犹犹豫豫的女人，
尤其是犹犹豫豫被人推着，
被人那个裹挟着往前走，
生完孩子的女的，
我就给你做个测试，
有多少女人是你没生孩子的时候，
其实你已经发现问题了，
但是就是被父母，
被这些亲。
推着往前走，
生了孩子了，
现在你后悔吗？
就你没有生孩子之前，
你已经发现了，
比如说他小气，
他不爱你，
他不关心你，
他不舍得给你花钱，
但是就是因为周围的亲戚朋友，
父母劝你，
你生了孩子了，
我就问你后不后悔，
对其实我这边有一个原因，
就是因为我就是结婚之前，
然后我父母就说给我全款买房了车，
因为我们家这个小的生我在给我父母打下手的那种，
所以说我每个月可能给我的就是说钱就四五千块钱，
可能就被我什么保险呀，
油耗啊，
078岁的消耗掉了，
我就没有存下来钱，
那我老公对我的意见很大，
他觉得这个小家好像就一直他一个人在存钱，
这一点上他对我意见就很大嘛，
平常如果要花他的钱，
他就很不爽，
你还想问我啥问题呢？
哎呀，
我现在又烦的很，
你要是没做好决定，
第一一定要做好避孕措施啊，
别在这个关键节点又让自己进退两难啊，
就他这么抠啊，
我真的就接受不了，
也改变不了，
就是他们家都是那种很抠很抠算计的那种，
不是姑娘啊，
我觉得我们自己身上也有问题，
首先不要想着我找个男人，
我嫁个男人，
我就一定能花上她的钱了，
千万不要这么想问题，
首先想的是我自己怎么能提高我的收入，
我不依赖于任何人，
我不用花男人的钱，
我跟你在一起是1+1>2的关系，
我不是说我嫁给男人了就一定是花你的钱，
我。
我花不着我就说你小气，
花不着我就说你抠，
先别这么想问题，
先是我自己怎么能多挣点钱，
我不用花别人的钱，
对他觉得我没有贡献，
就没挣钱，
就没贡献，
他就是那种认知嘛，
认知不同，
你也改变不了它，
你只有选择嘛。
然后还有一点，
姑娘啊，
龙飞姐，
我对你没有恶意啊，
就是我发现你讲话的时候会有一个习惯，
这个习惯趁年轻的时候改掉它，
这个习惯趁年轻改掉他，
好知道了不姐，
所以你给我的这建议就是趁着年轻人能撤就撤，
我明确的告诉你，
如果你生了孩子，
你跟他生活在一起的话，
有你的苦日子过，
看你愿不愿意过这样的苦日子，
你要愿意，
你就继续往下走，
你给我这个建议到背后你是怎么发现观察的了，
这还用观察吗？
第一，
从他的角度的话，
他认为即便是他一年换3个工作，
5个工作，
他也觉得他比你强，
第二，
他觉得你存在他的生命里的话，
你一直在给他拖后腿，
你没有给他带来任何的有价值的东西，
所以他瞧不起你，
第三，
你现在还没有说一分钱不挣呢，
你现在还挣着钱呢，
他都会觉得你是花了他的钱，
等到你怀孕生孩子的时候，
你真不挣，
你真的花她的钱的时候，
那个时候我跟你说，
在她眼里的话，
看你怎么看都不顺眼，
就是我感觉就是离了之后，
我感觉还是可能会有一个那种迷茫期。
姑娘，
你真的没有时间迷茫了啊，
没有时间矫情了啊，
你要么一门心思自己好好挣钱，
要么就是你赶紧相亲，
赶紧找对象，
因为你是没有办法抵抗你爸爸妈妈的这些舆论的压力的，
你肯定得生孩子的，
所以你现在真的没有时间伤春悲秋，
没有时间矫情，
好，
就这样啊，
拜拜，
有多少姐妹是跟她的经历挺相似的，
就是爸妈着急让你结婚，
二十八九了，
实在没办法了，
赶紧找个人结婚吧，
结完婚了之后，
你发现对方很小气，
很抠门，
不愿意给你花钱，
甚至说你自己花你挣的钱他都不高兴有没有？
就刚才那个姐妹，
你如果说继续往下过的话，
大概就是这个逻辑，
首先她本人她挣钱就不咋地是吧，
她一年换好多个工作，
其次她不怎么瞧得上，
就是不怎么瞧得起你，
她要但凡瞧得起你，
那你生病了，
你骨折了，
她不得好好表现啊，
不得很趁机会好好表现一下，
他才靠得住啊。
我如果说特别特别尊重我的对象，
特别瞧得起我的对象，
那他要是什么腰扭了脚扭了，
我不得好好表现一下呀，
我不得趁这个时间让他加深对我的信任啊，
我不得趁这个时间让他觉得，
哎呀，
全世界就我靠得住啊，
同意吗？
记得点赞关注哦。